Manufacturing creates a lot more than
just physical goods it also creates a
tremendous amount of data join us as we
talk to Oden technologies about how they
built a system to help manufacturers
analyze their data using IOT on this
episode of staff chat John thanks so
much for joining us today tell us a
little bit more about what Oden
technologies does mark thanks for
hosting me today
Oden is a company that focuses on the
Internet of Things for the industrial
sector with the specific mission of
improving the efficiency of the
manufacturing process for example we
have customers that produce you know you
know 500 million to a billion dollars
worth of product a year with high scrap
rates and by leveraging the Oden
platform they're able to reduce as one
factor the amount of scrap material that
they create in one case we've had a
customer that has managed to reduce
their scrap levels from 23% down to 9%
after implementing the open solution
that's great so it kind of captures a
lot of data and then can somehow relay
that back to the customers what does
that actual architecture look like a big
part of our architecture is around
managing the data that we've collected
from the users and making that data
available and actionable the starting
point for all of this is of course the
collection of data we start with a
device that sits on the factory floor
which collects data for the PLC's that
data then gets sent up to the cloud
using Google IOT we pull the data off of
Google ID using pub/sub we process that
data in real time we run whatever
learning models we have against the data
we also move the data over into a time
series database that sits on top of
BigTable as well as into bigquery in
addition to collecting data from the
machinery we also collect data from
other sources for example the operators
through an operator interface that we
on the factory floor if a machine is
down or there's a production problem the
operator will be able to add data or add
annotations that allows us to then go
back and do further analysis and that
comes back in through the cloud as well
much of that data then gets stored into
Google sequel and we can then pull that
data out as well using bigquery if you
could kind of go back to when you
started were there any like decisions
that you think you might change in
hindsight there are always decisions
that we would make differently one
example is our choice of to use a graph
database to represent the entities that
sit on the factory floor at the time
that the decision was made the
observation was that the factory floor
does not follow a strictly hierarchical
model and the way that you want to view
data on the factory floor does not
follow a strictly hierarchical model you
will sometimes want to organize your
data by factory line you will sometimes
want to organize your data by for
example type of type of machine we
decided to use a graph database at the
time we thought that it would accelerate
our development efforts and it did
however as we have scaled up we have
started to run into the limitations of
that graph of the graph database one of
the areas of concern is the fact that
graph databases tend to follow the
schema Blas and so what we have found is
that you know sometimes engineers will
introduce new features and because there
isn't a lot of structure you know by
introducing new features assumptions
that are inherent in the stimulus
architecture end up creating issues down
the road a second choice that we made
was to use an abstraction layer on top
of BigTable to support our time series
database the choice of BigTable
than great big table scales wonderfully
and more recently Google has added
replication capabilities and that has
been highly beneficial to our you know
redundancy strategy so we feel they were
much more reliable however at the time
we had a choice between a few different
abstraction layers and the abstraction
layer that we chose has reached somewhat
of a dead end in the public community
which means that it is not being
actively developed or worked on by
others and so features that were missing
at the time remain missing while other
abstraction layers have moved forward if
we were to start again today we would
probably use TS DB and I fully expected
over the next 12 to 18 months we will be
making a move to using TS to be as our
abstraction layer thanks so much for
coming in and telling us about how you
kind of build this architecture to scale
thank you for hosting me today and I
really enjoyed our chat try setting up
your own data pipeline by using this
hands-on solution that walks through
using dataflow and bigquery thanks for
watching and make sure to subscribe for
more great Google cloud platform content
we'll see you next time on stack chat
[Music]
you